et maintenant passe à notre terriens du
samedi soir
homo j'aimais cambon soir et feront tout
le monde motus le jeu gré mais tous les
jours à 10h50 sur france 2 nombreux sont
ceux qui vous ont vu au théâtre et au
cinéma par d'en tirer un second
certificat
au maire la boule noire
non au maire
nombreux sont ceux qui nous ont vus au
théâtre et au cinéma mais ce que les
gens ignorent c'est que votre enfance
thierry beccaro a été un calvaire en
fait vous avez été un enfant battu vous
racontez votre histoire dans un livre
publié chez plon qui s'appelle je suis
né à 17 ans
[Musique]
alors thierry beccaro vous êtes né le 19
octobre 1956 à l'hôpital militaire
béguin à saint-mandé dans le
val-de-marne votre mère était militaire
de carrière
votre père qui s'appelait warner way
était ouvrier chez renault et c'était un
rite alors ce qu'il faut savoir sur les
[ __ ] c'est qu'à l'époque on les
appelait les [ __ ] on les appelait les
macaronis on les appelle les spaghettis
pour deux raisons d'abord il n'est
manger le pain des français c'est ça
comme ça qu'on disait et ensuite leur
reprocher un petit peu l'engagement de
mussolini auprès des nazis donc régale
dans les années 50 c'était comme arabes
aujourd'hui un solvant votre père c'est
un très beau mec avec une moustache la
errol flynn
c'est donc diego de la vega c'est comme
ça qu'on gagne votre votre fils ma fille
aînée la plaie c'était à dix c'était
euros que cela super très beau gars qui
essayait d'échapper à son milieu
d'origine d'abord par son look parce
qu'il faisait attention à lui et par son
acharnement au travail parce qu'il
voulait monter dans l'échelle sociale ce
qui n'arrangeait rien c'est que la
famille de votre mère alors qu'ils
étaient de normandie française de souche
compo dit la famille voyait pas d'un
très bon oeil le fait que votre maman se
marie avec un [ __ ] j'ai crû comprendre
qu est-ce que c'est non non non non ici
la voir à thierry non c'est le dernier
mot un monde qui rapporte 100 points
mais surtout terni
le problème puisque j'ai travaillé un
peu le livre avec ma mère était obligé
de lui de poser ses questions et
effectivement ce que ce que tu dis c'est
là là c'est la réalité quoi c'est à dire
que les italiens avec
avec ma mère ça passe et oui un très
très bien d'après ce qu'elle a pu me
raconter à l'époque oui à l'époque
j'étais mal vue bien sûr alors vu la
modestie du train de vie de vos parents
et l'emploi du temps de votre mère qui
était militaire on peut pas dire que
votre arrivée dans la famille soit
considéré comme un cadeau du ciel vous
êtes d'accord visiblement
les parents avaient peut-être pas encore
les moyens d'habiter à l'appartement et
tout donc il a fallu me confier à crever
de ma mère va vos grands-parents qui
s'appelait anna et pietro étaient
arrivés d'italie au moment de la
dictature fasciste
alors on vous confiez votre grand mère
on dit que c'est provisoire sauf que le
provisoire va durer quatre ans mais
c'est assez cool la vie à l'époque pour
vous ne serait ce que parce qu'ils
avaient des voisins qui s'appelle edward
qui avait la télé c'est génial parce que
c'était c'est ce que j'ai appris ma fait
ligne a vite mais ces quatre en quatre
ans avec mémé radin c'est el hammam al
amara avec mon père les frères les
soeurs les cousins et cousines le
vélosolex way j'étais derrière ma
cousine je la tenais par les oranges
comme ça une bonne époque quoi rouler à
150 à l'heure en solex ensoleillé les
criminels de guerre
et est ce qui était génial c'est que il
y avait ceux qui l'avaient ce qui ne
l'avait pas ouais et les frais les
doigts monsieur madame edouard j'avais
la télé il avait la télé est donc le
mercredi soir n'y avait pas école le
lendemain on allait voir la piste aux
étoiles mais voilà gilles margaritis
exceptionnel
je
la piste aux étoiles roger lanzac
absolem extraordinaire émission que je
regardais comme vous évidemment alors
j'ai très bien pour vous mes beaux
parents il passe finalement le week-end
ils sont toujours pressés vous les voyez
pas beaucoup à l'époque hein je les vois
pas beaucoup et c'est comme si quand ils
viennent je me dis peut-être qu'ils
viennent me me chercher et oui mais non
bah non je reste avec mémé ramena parce
que d'abord je suis très très heureux et
je le dis souvent j'aurais pu aller
n'importe où avec elle c'était une
époque où le le temps n'existait pas
c'est une époque bénie malheureusement
la parenthèse enchantée va se refermer
brutalement en 1960 avec la naissance de
votre soeur valérie là vous retournez
chez vos parents vous vous apercevez
d'ailleurs que vient moi que j'en ai
même pas annoncé que vous alliez avoir
une petite soeur
j'ai un souvenir où je n'en ai pas
justement
vasseur valérie que jure que j'adore que
j'embrasse mais je ne me souviens pas
d'avoir vu ma mère enceinte fabre donc
je découvre une petite soeur alors vos
parents ont déménagé là vous passez du
pavillon à la tour et ça a l'air de rien
mais vous passez dans l'univers
horizontale un univers verticale circuit
étant 11e étage ça change tout quoi ah
oui là je me retrouve dans un immeuble
il n'y a plus la campagne a plus le les
vapeurs de la solidarité entre voisins
c'est l'indifférence générale et là
c'est un peu l'ennui quoi cette solitude
à la maison il faut dire les choses la
tension est palpable
votre mère est très belle elle a
participé à des concours de miss étant
jeune et votre père est maladivement
jaloux la savoir entourée d'hommes en
uniforme parce qu'elle bossait quand
même à l'armée lui ça lui pose des
problèmes c'est l'italien jaloux a
adressée soit la paire m'a raconté
c'était terrible c'était terrible votre
père il va chercher systématiquement à
la sortie de la base aérienne où elle
travaille comme le mec est jalouse déjà
ça n'arrange rien ils sortent tous les
deux le soir ils ont une vie quand même
quand vous avez votre grand mère vienne
pas vous voir quand vous êtes chez eux
ils sortent le soir mais très angoissée
de vous retrouver chez vous tout seul on
était dans l'appart 11e étage tout seul
avec ma soeur et j'entendais dans le
couloir le le le bruit des talons
aiguilles de ma mère qui rentre avec la
voix sur un clac clac et la clé dans la
serrure et la clé dans la serrure et je
faisais ça y est ils sentent retour
parce que dans la nuit comme ça c'est
marie quand on n'est pas grand on a peur
on a peur on flippe un peu et alors le
vrai drame en fait de tout ça c'est la
violence de votre père il s'est extrait
en fait de sa classe sociale il t'arrive
à monter il est un des meilleurs
vendeurs de vol faut donc voilà il s'en
est bien sorti mais il est quand même un
peu désillusionnés sur sa ville un peu
déçu par ce qui lui arrive et bois ouais
ça s'est il boit il boit les apéros
c'est pas le sas et voit pas une
bouteille de police parce qu'on appelle
la police mans col blanc c'est ça c'est
à la fin à la fin de la fin de la
journée on va prendre un pot et puis
tiens tiens la békaa les attentes
immenses et samian et puis et puis voilà
le problème c'est quand il boit les
coups pleuvent quand vous avez une
mauvaise note à l'école ou quand vous
faites un geste un peu bizarre où un
regard un peu bizarre il suffit d'un
rien pour entraîner un début de gifler
de plus chiffrée des défraiements
d'aider des faits s'est évadé des
dérouillées assez carabinée et pour
revenir à l'école j'étais pris moi dans
un dilemme qui était hallucinant c'est
que j'étais coincé entre l'obligation de
rapporter des bonnes notes à l'école
parce que sinon je risque est
directement prendre une mais j'étais
aussi condamné à en avoir pas trop de
bonnes notes à l'école parce que sinon
j'étais un fayot et je risquais de me
faire dérouiller à la la récré alors
quand votre père nous frappe vous
comprenez pas évidemment pourquoi vous
avez besoin dans recroquevillé dans
l'escalier et vous culpabiliser parce
qu'un gosse que tu frappes il se dit
pourquoi il me frappe j'ai dû faire une
connerie et ce qui était vachement
difficile avec votre père c'est qu'en
fait il il vous battez et ensuite ils
venaient dans votre chambre pour vous
dire je t'aime ça c'était c'était quand
même incroyable quoi c'est à dire je me
prenais une rouste assez sévères et puis
ils venaient m'embrasser soir après et
alors je me disais bon bah bon bah ça va
ça veut dire qu'ils m'aiment alors c'est
bien parce que je me disais que j'avais
dû faire quelque chose de pas bien mais
quand vous quand vous en parler
aujourd'hui là vous dites mais c'est pas
possible c'est un bonheur de faire une
chose pareille quoi il ya quand même des
bons moments c'est vrai il faut écouter
brassens il vous fait écouter frank
sinatra il vous fait écouter dean martin
lysanne andino martineau parce que ça me
tallien tiering ça c'est un moment
formidable parce que c'est celle et
c'est ça qu'il faut dire c'est que via
les rayons de soleil mais il ya là il ya
la joie du dimanche matin ilia iachine à
tradi de martin et il ya l'os
malheureusement c'était ça aussi le
contrôle de vie sains ouais ouais parce
qu'un jour ça allait et le lendemain un
s'agit bien du tout c'est à dire que oui
en 1966 de 10 ans vos parents vous
inscrivez vous au club de basket la
colombe est là pour la première fois de
votre vie vous découvrez le plaisir
d'être acclamé mais vos parents viennent
jamais vous voir en fait ouais ils sont
je crois qu'ils sont jamais venus jamais
ouais j'ai été vachement bien en plus
alors là bon c'est horrible parce que
dans les vestiaires du basket vous
cachez vos marques de coups c'est à dire
vous voyez je vous avais peur que vos
copains voit sa prison que je n'ai
jamais dit je n'ai jamais raconté parce
qu'un enfant c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est que ça protège ses parents non ça
va pas dénoncer ça va pas raconter moi
j'ai fait mon parcours jusqu'à
aujourd'hui sans jamais évoquer quoi que
ce soit concernant mes parents et tout
ça est bien d'abord y avait une espèce
d'orgueil et puis le raconter c'est
quelque part le revivre ouais donc
alors en juin 1973 les 17 en une nuit
vous dormez pas vous entendez des bruits
étranges dans le salon votre père se
tient debout un fusil à la main et il
vise votre mère
ca c c'est quelque chose c'est indicible
sur le moment c'est à dire que là on est
en état de sidération c'est la
sidération dire que en fait je vais
saluer mon père je retourne dans ma
chambre je m'allonge et j'entends comme
ce bruit là je l'entendrai toujours
comme un bruit sourd de cavalcade comme
si on secours après quoi donc je sors de
ma chance je vous la porte du couloir et
là je vois mon père avec le fusil ma
mère à côté il immobile courageuse et
moi je dis papa avec ses papa qu'est ce
que tu fais
donc là il se reprend évidemment et au
lieu de se servir de fusible là il
attrape la mer sa part la gorge
et là
tout comme je le dis là je suis mort là
c'est à dire que là tout à coup on ne
peut pas imaginer ce qui vous arrive
alors après il fait asseoir il me dit
tout ce qu'il a à me dire mais on est
passé ailleurs celle-ci quand même quand
tu es né personne ne voulait toi c'est à
dire qu'on ne savait pas on avait
peut-être parce qu'il fallait pour tu
pour te loger un bond à taper différents
endroits et heureusement mais meyrannes
n'a été là quoi alors ce jour là vous
mourrez et vous naissez aussi c'est à
dire que là vous êtes au bout et que
vous ratez votre bac mais le soir des
résultats du bac même si vous n'avez pas
votre bac vous allez chez une copine qu
organise une fête et là vous oubliez
tous vos vacances et vous riez la fille
vous aime bien elle vous conseille
miracle de vous inscrire dans un cours
de théâtre y ce qui est extra bien dans
notre histoire c'est qu'à un moment ça
se retourne complètement vous voyez le
côté solaire du monde et non plus le
côté
n'est pas vrai et puis c'est c'est le
pam ann unis à laurent je vais dire ça
il y avoue c'était un peu le plaisir de
changer le changer de peau de dire
quelqu'un d'autre pas tout ça m'a changé
la vie parmi les cours de théâtre ont
aidé à ça et ensuite en
1978 vous imaginez devenir instituteur
quand un ami de votre père comme quoi
votre père a quand même pas été
complètement inutiles et c'est ça qui il
est ami avec joe donat qui faisait
toutes les nuits sur france inter tu
sais du samedi au dimanche et que
l'accordéon et il demande un jeu de
nagui a pas un job pour vous je donne à
vous brancher avec radio france
et la partir de là tout s'enchaîne de
données l'assistant de macha béranger la
fameuse masia bérenger a qui ont raconté
ces problèmes la nuit vous appelez à
l'oma chars et en 80 donc vous avez 25
ans vous faites votre première émission
sur radio bleue là ça y est c'est parti
ici le pouvoir
résilience est heureux qu'il y ait eu un
nc il ya une de trot sont entrepris
suite on connaît à ces matin bonheur
c'est 40 degrés à l'ombre
et bien sûr
après le théâtre
moi j'ai vu débuter au théâtre les films
et téléfilms voilà maintenant bon
thierry beccaro on sait qui c'est vous
écrivez depuis 50 ans je me bats contre
des démons qui ne cesse de se rappeler à
moi est ce que cette enfance douloureuse
vous revient de temps en temps par
bouffer ou est ce que c'est une
souffrance l'attend non ça me revient ça
revient comme ça de temps en temps comme
on sent bien que le sac à dos et plus
léger ouais j'ai fait tout le travail
d'analysé vous avez fait de la thérapie
on voit là la thérapie commun qui vous
aide et puis vous arriver un jour à dire
merci maman merci papa ça c'est fou le
jour où on m'a dit et si vous disiez
merci à votre père et à votre mère pour
tout ça là j'ai cru que j'allais tomber
de l'ada chaises et j'ai réfléchi j'ai
dit mais quel parcours ça m'a permis de
faire cesser formidable et c'est pour ça
que j'ai fait ce livre pour dire aux
autres voilà si vous passez par là il ya
du soleil à l'arrivée voilà je suis mais
à 17 ans c'est publié chez plon les
corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu